next up kevin michelle we're going to
talk about best actor
um
i mean this one i think we're all going
to be united on yeah yeah absolutely
right yeah like yeah one two three say
the name uh-huh
no it's true well he's won everything it
really feels like it's his time but do
you remember last year we all predicted
chadwick boseman was going to win he won
everything and then anthony hawkins
upset in the end so it's not in the bag
yet but i would be really shocked if
will smith didn't walk home with an
oscar i am just going to be furious
um it's his time
i mean this is him at his best it
deserves an award totally and i love the
arc of will smith's career i mean think
about it we we knew we got to know him
as like a music artist and then the
fresh prince of bel-air and then this
like action star and to be turning in
this kind of work now he just you never
put will smith in a box and i love that
he's doing this i know it's true i love
range it's so sexy um well our but he is
up against some heavyweights guys i mean
he's up against you know denzel
washington
who who is nominated for macbeth he is
the most nominated black actor of all
time which is a really amazing fact i
loved hearing that i didn't surprise me
but again these are the kind of facts
that i think are so interesting mm-hmm
um and so i just shout out andrew
garfield too and tick tick boom did you
guys please do it please do it
[Applause]
yeah
and our audience actually voted for him
to win this year wow
43 wow wow wow
audience
that's something to think about because
he was so good i mean i came in the next
day after seeing this and i said oh my
god michelle yeah yeah if there's
someone that i feel like could upset
will smith it would be andrew garfield
in this category i i definitely i
definitely think so but the audience man
bucking the trent i know um rossie talk
about best actor well i have a real
opinion here you do i do
this is the category everybody is
watching it is so up in the air nobody
knows for sure let's take a look at the
nominees nicole kidman won the golden
globe jessica chastain won the sag and
uh
the experts have no idea who's going to
win this drew who do you think it's
going to be michelle i'm going to count
to three and we'll say the names at the
same time okay all right one two three
jessica that's a good tip okay
yeah yeah that's who i'm rooting for
same
thing
i
loved this movie um
she's just also been such a force
for so many years she's what they call a
scene stealer it doesn't matter the role
the size she
just captivates you i know this project
was very personal for her to her yeah
when she got the rights to this she
really wanted to tell the story that
tammy fay while she was you know in
terms of a christian conservative she
was also very compassionate she was
inclusive she also reached out to the
lgbtq plus uh community and wanted to
make sure they felt loved and heard and
so when she got to do this it meant
everything to her because it very easily
could have been a caricature yeah
absolutely so many people did characters
of hers to celebrate a woman who just
against all odds kept saying
can't we love people for who they really
are
i'm like oh my god
exactly i
i agree with you tammy say can't we just
love people for who they are yeah
and jessica just embodies her yeah she
does such a great choice okay let's
check out our viewer poll what did they
say all right oh okay
rossitel kristen stewart for spencer
that's your princess diana fascination
yeah yeah you know that's what that is
kristen stewart had been snubbed for a
couple of other awards you know she
wasn't nominated for so there was
question whether it should be dominated
at all she could win i'm telling you
this is the race that is wide open all
right we're going to move to best
director michelle kevin who's taking it
home
again heading heart here for me my heart
is with steven spielberg my head says
jane campion
i'm rooting for stephen but but jane
campion's kind of been the award
season's darling too and and in 93 she
became only the second woman to be
nominated for best director that was for
the piano the first was lena wertmuller
and 78 for seven beauties and if she
were to win for power of the dog um then
and you add that to chloe's owl last
year that's the first females to ever
win back-to-back best director which i
think is phenomenal and
the power of the dog is such a beautiful
thing it's a director's film that's what
it is and i think that for the academy
it is folks who look at that it's a
director's film but steven spielberg is
the man he's the king of movies and um
you know if he wins for west side story
he would join the esteemed group of
directors with um eight well he has
eight total nods right now martin
scorsese billy wilder um william
weiler um spielberg can also he's
already won twice for schindler's and
saving pride ryan so this will be his
third oscar and that would be an
esteemed list of directors who've won
three times absolutely yeah well let's
see who the viewers picked um what is it
yeah
let's go
let's go
um i do love that you know people are so
outspoken about women winning in this
category so if jane campion wins that's
fantastic chloe zao last year um you
know natalie portman came out with the
dress with all the women's names oh yeah
they weren't nominated yes so you know
advocacy works and we should all keep
our voices heard um
drew it's very important that women are
getting the opportunities to direct
these big movies these good movies a
diversity of directors makes a diversity
of great films
i agree
[Music]